[Music]
ha no YouTube just Louis in my friends
this is guns in here welcome to my
seventh episode of no in Tulsa cylinder
Pluto from the black perspective in this
episode we are going to look at the moon
eight Queen captures up six by white
which arises after the following model
evil C Phi Knight to f3 Knight to c6 d4c
captures d4 Knight captures D full ePHI
Knight to be fire and after the moon a
six when white put this nine on a d6
square with a check we are going to lop
it off and then challenge the white
queen wait Queens up six now by far the
second most popular choice by the white
camp is to capture the screen which
personally I think is an inferior choice
and in most of the cases it is choosen
by either inferior player or a person
who doesn't know anything about this
video so by doing this Queen trade white
thinks that he is safe and avoid the
theory but the matter of fact is after
the Moon Knight captures f6 not only
black has a superior piece development
but white has to be very careful as he
has to dodged a lot of bullets in order
to achieve the equal position Black
Knight is already hitting on e4 so
accordingly White has two choices and
amongst them Knight to c3 is a mainline
however there are few games in the
database continue with f3 which is in
fact a completely inferior version as it
allows our dramatic break defy once
again renewing the thread so white
response is almost forced he has to
capture on d5 but after night
to defy this position is already looking
quite superior for the black camp I
don't think so we should look at further
but just for your reference I like to
show you one of my quick win in this
line where my lord it is 1600 opponent
continue with a three stopping my knight
intrusion but after Bishop to a fire I
think white is already in a huge mess
here it doesn't matter whether white
continue with c4 or Bishop to c4 let's
say in the game white continue with
Bishop to c4 attacking the knight but he
got this rude shock Knight to D fall as
if I'm telling him I have a more potent
threat than yours
well obviously after long think white
find nothing better than castle on the
Kings side which allows me to capture on
c2 with a tempo and after rook to a -
here comes the winning more of the game
Knight d2 III attacking two sports and
even after Bishop captures III and
Knight captures III the threat remain as
it is and the only logical way to defend
both the threat is to play rook to c1
but guess what
after nightcap to see for my opponent to
his horror find out that just within
16th mu of the game he is a piece down
for obviously no reason so let's start
with Knight to c3 which is a main line
from this position and again see
yourself with each Moon Knight to before
Black is creating a threat and white is
playing a defensive game starting from
ninth move the game isn't that amazing
the threats are very obvious number one
there's a folk looming on c2 and the
second and hematocrit defy
which I don't think so right and prevail
from this position well White has three
options and let's see each bite on the
first one King to d1 is a pretty bad one
due to the simple reply Knight to g4 so
now we are striking on other side of the
ball and White King is completely
overlord so accordingly the only moon in
this position is Bishop to e3 saving the
threat but that makes life very easy for
the black cam as after Knight captures
e3 pawn captures e3 and the mood d6 not
only White King is misplaced but White
has this horrible pawn at the center of
the ball and if anybody is playing for
the win it is obviously the black camp
the second tricky option what can try
over here is King to d2 which at first
sight looks very strange right because
it is blocking his own bishop
but what has a point to prove as it
completely stopped over defy idea you
may wonder why what's wrong with going
ahead with d5
well here is the problem why it has this
nice sequence starting with a three so
if you move the knight then the d5 pawn
drops so accordingly black responses
force a black has to play d4 but after
pawn takes pawn takes White has this
lovely move King to e3 saving the
important key for porn and when black
capture on b2 white can simply recapture
waste bishop and not only this position
as equal material but with this two
raking bishop I think it is only
favorable to the white cam
so that is the reason why we should
completely avoid if I move when white
play the move King today - okay so what
to do well here comes the first memory
marker guys this is the only variation
when white continue with King 2d - we
are going to respond with d6 and more or
less we are going to prepare defy at the
later stage of the game let me show you
a sample line how we can achieve this
the most popular choice here for the
white camp is to play a three hitting
the night our night drop backs to c6 and
now in order to free up his dark square
Bishop White has to continue with King
to even liberating his bishops but we
are more than happy as after Bishop to
e6 as you can see the d5 break is
unavoidable for the white camp now I
like to show you one of the very
interesting game in the database which
will give you a clear path how good
black position is in this vision at this
point white continue with Bishop to e3
and yup we can play defy but I like what
black did in this game he continued with
Knight to e7 so his idea is very obvious
when white take the D file with rook to
d1 he continued with d5 and his thinking
is absolutely spot-on as after Knight
captures defy Knight captures d5 pawn
captures defy rather than Bishop
captures defy he want to take the d5
pawn with a knight which also hitting
the poor bishop on a three square bishop
to c1 happen and now every move comes
with a temple rook to see it attacking
the pawn Bishop to b3 defending and now
the second threat fi planning to play a
fool and then grab on see to so white
neutralized this once again with the MU
f3 and finally black castle on the Kings
side well I figure out that he has to do
something on c2 so he defended with C 3
but now black deliver this star mu
Knight to f4 hitting two sports and
white really do not want to play Bishop
to have fun so he thought that okay I
can chop it off and do black this double
pawn but the matter of fact is this
position is quite favorable to the black
cam let's see how quickly white polish
and fallen apart King to have to happen
which liberate the h1 rook and
accordingly black Harris this demon rook
with Bishop to b3 rook to even happen
but I think this is a great inaccuracy
by white camp has after rook C to d8
attacking the bishop bishop to beavin
and now rook to D to check conforms
black advantage
why you may ask I can simply block it
with ruh right well yes you can but
after rook F to b8 it doesn't matter
whether white continue with rook to even
or Bishop to a5 Bishop to c4 is coming
on the next move which confirms the
black veering advantage in the game why
decided to grab the pawn but that
doesn't help as Bishop to c4 happens on
the board and after rook takes rook
takes King to even and now rook captures
g2 you can see with the naked eye not
only this rook is wonderfully placed on
the second rank but what Luke on the h1
is never come in the picture and after
few moves black indeed win the game in a
star so it is very obvious there after
King to d1 or King to d2 blackgate a
pleasant winning advantage so that's why
the main line start with Bishop to d3
defending the c2 pawn after this move
more or less black has three good
choices and amongst them my
recommendation is you should go ahead
with the mu D Phi however by end of this
lecture somehow if you don't like my
line then you are more than welcome to
look at other variation which I have
covered in the daft which will also
provide you a good alternative to this
variation well D Phi is a very direct
move and why it has to take on D Phi
however it also contained a nasty trap
which happen in few games where white
continue with a3 which is a pretty bad
move as after the following sequence D
captures e for hitting the bishop
night cap to Z fool but now comes the
point as after night captures d3 check
pawn captures d3 you can see that is a
weak bond sitting on d3 and the only
thing we have to avoid here is night
exchange so after the moon night to defy
white has this permanent loose weakness
on d3 which is more than sufficient to
exploit in the endgame ok so he kept his
defies forced and after this here comes
the second important memory marker guys
whenever eleven he captures me if I
happen do not forget to give this check
which gives white this double pawn and
then we can continue with Bishop to a5
getting one of our pawn back with a very
comfortable game the only critical move
in this position is Bishop to g5 however
if you open and continue with other
moves such as King to e2 defending on d3
then we can play the move at six
stopping Bishop to g5 and as you can see
I have highlighted by the arrows very
simple but effective plan of campaign by
black that is castle on the Queen side
and then lop it off this d5 pawn which
gives immense pressure on the d3 square
and sooner or later
black indeed get the d3 pawn and in fact
the winning advantage so apart from
Bishop to g5 if you open in place any
other moves then this is the plan of
campaign from the black side however
white indeed has the move Bishop to g5
and if you opponent reach to this
position then definitely he has some
knowledge about this video anyways the
plus side is I have done some heavy
research in this line and I like to
point out some important novel
which will not only surprise your
opponent but give you enough chance to
go for the win even in such a variations
the first move is very obvious Bishop
captures d3 if White Castle
then we can play Bishop to a5 and you
can check out my analysis in the PGN
however the most frequent choice by the
white camp is to play a rook to d1
attacking the bishop more often and not
all the games continue with Bishop to a5
or Bishop to g6 which i think is a
reasonable option but here comes my
surprising suggestion guys as I am going
to propose a very unique move Bishop
could be fine which at first sight looks
completely stupid right as white can
take up a bishop and give us a double
pawn on the B file so for example a
sample line can run like this Bishop
captures up six point captures f6 and
now white can decide which direction he
can go let's look at two option the
first one where white doesn't take of a
bishop and continue with Knight to e4
attacking on f6 Square to whom we will
defend with King to his seven again
setting up a nice trap and I bet many of
your opponent cannot resist this as
after the move d6 it looks very obvious
that what is going to win a pawn as you
can't play the Moon King to me six so
black has to play King to d8 and now
what can be the more natural than Knight
captures app-6 winning upon and thinking
about a full point well guess what this
is exactly black once and has after rook
to CH I came white is a huge trouble
well white has to stop black intrusion
of the rook
so King to do to is obvious response but
here comes the star mu which gives plant
a slight advantage in this position can
you guessed it well it is this amazing
moon h5 the point is after the move rook
to even attacking of a second pawn black
has this nice sequence rook to at six
attacking the knight and after Knight to
e4 and the move f5 not only we can able
to remove this night but after rook
captures d6 King to c1 rook captures d1
rook captures d1 and the MU King to be 7
suddenly black get this wonderful pawn
chain at the center of the board and his
King is well placed to support H and if
you put this in any professional engine
it will tell you that black has very
good winning chances in this endgame
last but not least what happens if y
decided to capture of a bishop well this
is where our analysis comes into the
picture as after Knight captures b5 pawn
captures B Phi we are already hitting
the a to pawn so white responses force
white has to play the move a 3 and now
we are going to target this week d5 pawn
with King to his 7 so first we want to
block it and then try to pressurize this
d5 pawn with of a rook sitting on c5 or
to penetrate on the C 2 square well in
fact there is no game in the database so
I just like to show you a simple line
how good black position is first white
castle on the King side connect his room
and accordingly we are going to grab the
C file with rook 2 CH and when y try to
soften up our pawn
Jean with f4 we are going to penetrate
on the second rank which rook to c2
attacking on b2 so white responses force
white has to play a rope to have to but
after rook captures up to King catches
f2 and the MU King to d6 believe it or
not this position is very favorable to
the black camp the problem in the white
campaigns let's say after King to e3 we
have this winning plan starting with B
for pressurizing the a3 square so white
has to take this bone but now black
reveal his nasty idea namely rook to e4
not only grabbing the pawn back with a
pressure on b2 but after the equity
response let's say F captures if I F
capture Z Phi and the move B Phi black
has this winning mu in this position
fi completely restricting the white king
and the same time making this white rook
very passive defending on the d5 and on
top of everything black has a simple
plan to execute namely look to before
taking on before and then taking on d5
and the net result is black obtained are
completely winning endgame
that's it guys with this detailed
analysis now you are confident enough to
meet the MU Queen captures f6 remember
when you opponent defend with Knight to
c3 play this star mu night to be for
attacking on c2 and same time looking at
this juicy defy break and no matter
however white riggles black get are very
comfortable and easy to play game at
just ninth move of the king
thank you for watching this video feel
free to like subscribe and comment and I
will meet you in my next episode very
soon bye and take care
you